wir haben ja in den letzten vier wochen
also seit beginn der harten maßnahmen
und der kontakt beschränkungen insgesamt
sehr viel erreicht es ist insbesondere
gelungen die infektionszahlen soweit
unter kontrolle zu bringen dass sie
nicht mehr exponentiell steigen und dass
dies gelungen ist dass der re
produktionsfaktor jetzt auch unter 1 ist
dass wir an etlichen tagen mehr genesene
haben als neu infizierte
das ist vorneweg den bürgerinnen und
bürgern zu verdanken die alle
einschränkungen bezug über großer
disziplin und insgesamt auch sehr viel
geduld getragen haben und auch heute
möchte ich dafür von ganzem herzen noch
einmal danke sagen es gibt also eine
wachsende zahl von genießen
und das müssen wir uns gerade zu beginn
dieser woche in der er die ersten
ökonomen den kampf wieder und wieder
klappt natürlich fällt das schwer
dann wissen wir eben nicht genau was die
folge davon ist und deshalb müssen wir
schrittweise langsam und vorsichtig
vorgehen
denn es wäre jammerschade wenn wir
sehenden auges in einen rückfall ging
wenn der sehenden auges die ersten
erfolge gefährden würden und deshalb
dürfen wir keine sekunde lang
leichtfertig oder leichtsinnig werden
wir dürfen uns keine sicher keine
sekunde in sicherheit wiegen ist ganz
ganz wichtig dass wir sozusagen wieder
leichtsinnig sind noch uns in sicherheit
wiegen sondern wir müssen wachsam und
diszipliniert bleiben und wenn ich von
dir rede dann sind wir das alle die
bürgerinnen und bürger dieses landes
und damit das auch ganz klar ist ich
weiß ja um die not vieler menschen
ich weiß um die not von eltern und
kindern um die not gerade auch von
alleinerziehenden
ich sehe die not so vieler in der
gastronomie bei den hotels und ich sehe
die not zu vieler menschen die um die
zukunft ihres geschäfts ihres betriebs
ihres unternehmens bangen
auch die not vieler künstler die nicht
wissen wie es für sie weitergehen kann
ich sehe die erwartung der kirchen und
religionsgemeinschaften die den
gläubigen mehr als nur online
gottesdienste ermöglichen möchten und
die sehnsucht von gläubigen in den
gottesdiensten endlich wieder die
gemeinschaft mit anderen erleben zu
können
ich sehe natürlich das dringende
bedürfnis das freiheitsrecht der
versammlung und demonstrationen wieder
wahrnehmen zu können
und ich weiß auch um die not einsamer
menschen die ihre einsamkeit jetzt noch
viel viel stärker spüren als sonst und
das heißt ja auch diese pandemie
verlangt uns allen in diesem lande
neben einzelnen aber auch der
gemeinschaft ziemlich viel ab aber ich
bin zugleich davon überzeugt dass wir
all dieser not all den hoffnungen und
erwartungen wünschen und ansprüchen am
besten begegnen wenn wir gerade am
anfang dieser pandemie weiter auch die
kraft zu harten und stellingen maßnahmen
aufbringen
ich will noch einmal daran erinnern dass
wir am letzten mittwoch gemeinsam mit
den ministerpräsidenten ja beschlossen
haben dass bis mindestens dritter mai
die regeln weiter gelten 15 meter
abstand im freien aufenthalt zu hause
nur im eigenen haus stand im freien auch
nur mit dem eigenen hausstand oder aber
mit einer person die nicht zu diesem
haus stand gehört keine touristischen
reisen keine reisen sozusagen in die
ferne